we have a voicemail number that number
is
2192 David P here's a caller
who is worried about me and I always
appreciate concern from people in the
audience
hey David it's James I'm watching some
of your earlier videos from uh I guess
not not super earlier but a few years
from a couple years ago one particular
stands out
um I believe it was called caller needs
help with Jewish person and you seem
like you're in a much better place
you're in much higher spirits of the
time you've been more joyful uh but then
you you have recently I was wondering
are you all right did something happen
you seem kind of down in the dumps
recently well I hope you're okay the
concern
um nothing in particular has happened
um certainly the State of Affairs in the
United States is quite sad that is true
so I think it would be logical as
someone who's steeped in how things are
going
uh to be sort of concerned but at the
same time the video that the caller is
referring to I believe happened while
Trump was President which was certainly
a dark time in American history so no I
appreciate the concern nothing in
particular is wrong I mean listen let's
be honest chasing around a baby is
exhausting so if anything could be
blamed for tiredness or whatever
um certainly it would be it would be
that but no everything is fine thanks
for asking on the bonus show today folks
we have a fantastic bonus show today I
just got back from a wedding in
California I am going to talk about uh
elements that took place on the flight
some unfortunate confrontations that
took place not good I'm going to talk
about running into some really nice
folks who watch the show while I was in
the Bay area of California met some
great people just by chance there was no
event or anything just ran into some
people uh I am going to talk about what
else am I going to talk about
I I have stories I have stories from
California we are also going to talk
about an investigation into the cause of
the implosion of that Titanic
submersible we're going to discuss that
and also Japan has a plan to boost birth
rates we've talked about the plan before
is it a viable plan we're starting to
gather data
one city
has reason to hope that this is a good
plan for Japan to raise birth rates
where birth rates are getting
dangerously low from a political
standpoint all of those stories and more
will be in none other than today's bonus
show oh the bonus show where you want to
make money everybody else that makes
money to find themselves is bad and of
course after being back for one day I
will be off for the next three weeks no
I'm kidding I'm we're back we're back
for a while uh before before the next
break it's not even really a break
anymore you know by the way let's just
talk a little bit about the guest hosts
every time we have guest hosts I get
emails all right I'm going to tell
everybody right now
I know that not everybody likes the
guest hosts I know it because every
guest host we have no matter what we get
emails from people saying I couldn't
bear to watch it some people liked Luke
but they didn't like Pat some people
like Pat but they didn't like Luke some
people didn't like either some people
said both were fine but it wasn't that
good so I'm just gonna put it out there
we used to have no shows when I would be
away it wasn't really
robust one of the things I've wanted to
do is have a more robust show that can
continue when I'm gone we now have
multiple people who can do the producer
role we have a rotating cast of guest
hosts I understand and I'm flattered
that when I'm gone
some people say David I'd rather have
you here and that makes sense because
you're watching this show or listening
to this show rather than some other show
so I get that and I love that and I'm
flattered by it but you don't have to
email me that you don't like the guest
hosts or all of the guest hosts because
I know that not everybody likes them
viewership goes down when we have a
guest host but my opinion is and people
in the audience seem to agree it's
better to have a guest host rather than
no show
or a repeat show because if it's part of
your routine to listen to a podcast on
the way to work on the way to the gym
whatever and you don't necessarily want
to find something else we have something
there and I think viewership is usually
down about 30 percent when we have guest
hosts which isn't really that bad I have
to tell you all right so
you you you can always email for any
reason but if you're just emailing in to
say hey I didn't like the guest host we
know we see that in the data and we're
going to continue working to have a
great rotating slate of hosts that will
hold down the fort until I get back all
right more about my trip on the bonus
show we'll be back tomorrow we have a
very strong week of programming ahead